what was the the hardest thing like uh
so you said walking over rough terrain
like the just taking footsteps i mean
people
there's it's so dramatic and painful in
a certain kind of way to watch
these videos from the drc of robots
falling
yep it's just so heartbreaking i don't
know maybe it's because
for me at least we anthropomorphize the
robot
um of course there's one for some reason
like humans falling is funny
uh for i don't it's some dark reason i'm
not sure why
it is so but it's also like tragic and
painful
and uh so speaking of which i mean what
what made the robots fall
and fail in your view so i can tell you
exactly what happened on our we i
contributed one of those our team
contributed one of those spectacular
falls
um every one of those falls the
has a complicated story i mean at one
time the power effectively went out
on the robot because it had been sitting
at the door
waiting for the green light to be able
to proceed and its batteries
you know and therefore it just fell
backwards and smashed his head across
his ground and it was hilarious but it
wasn't because of bad software
right um but for ours so the hardest
part of the challenge the hardest task
in my view was getting out of the
polaris
it was actually relatively easy to drive
the polaris we have
can you tell the stars starting to
introduce the story of the car
[Laughter]
people should watch this video i mean
the the the thing you've come up with is
just brilliant but uh anyway sorry
what's uh
yeah we kind of joke we call it the big
robot little car problem because
um somehow the race organizers decided
to give us a 400 pound humanoid and they
also provided the vehicle
which was a little polaris and the robot
didn't really fit in the car so you
couldn't drive the car
with your feet under the steering column
we actually had to straddle
the the main column of the uh
and have basically one foot in the
passenger seat one foot in the driver's
seat
and then drive with our left hand
but the hard part was we had to then
park the car get out of the car
uh it didn't have a door that was okay
but it's just uh
getting up from crouched from sitting
when you're in this
very constrained environment uh first of
all i remember after watching those
videos i was much more cognizant of how
how hard is it it is for me to get in
and out of the car
and out of the car especially like it's
actually a really difficult control
problem
yeah and i i'm very cognizant of it when
i'm like injured
for whatever reason it's really hard
yeah so how did you
how did you approach it so we had a you
know you think of
nasa's operations and they have these
checklists you know pre-launch
checklists and they're like we weren't
far off from that we had this big
checklist and
on the first day of the competition we
were running down our checklist and one
of the things we had to do
we had to turn off the controller the
piece of software that was running
that would drive the left foot of the
robot in order to
accelerate on the gas and then we turned
on our balancing controller
and the nerves jitters of the first day
of the competition
someone forgot to check that box and
turn that controller off
so um we used a lot of motion planning
uh
to figure out a sort of configuration of
the robot that we get up and
and over we relied heavily on our
balancing controller
and and basically there was when the
robot was in one of its most precarious
you know sort of configurations trying
to
sneak its big leg out of the out of the
side
the other controller that thought it was
still driving
told its left foot to go like this and
and that wasn't good um but but it
turned disastrous for us
because um what happened was a little
bit of push here actually
if you we have videos of us you know
running into the robot with a
10-foot pole and it kind of will recover
but this is a case where
there's no space to recover so a lot of
our secondary balancing mechanisms about
like take a step to recover they were
all disabled because we were in the car
and there's no place to step
so we're relying on our just lowest
level reflexes
and even then i think just hitting the
foot on the seat
on the on the floor we probably could
have recovered from it but the thing
that was bad that happened is when we
did that and we
jostled a little bit the tailbone of our
robot
had was only a little off the seat it
hit the seat
and the other foot came off the ground
just a little bit and nothing in our
plans
had ever told us what to do if your
butt's on the seat
and your feet are in the air feeding
there and then
the thing is once you get off the script
things can go very wrong because even
our state
estimation our system that was trying to
collect all the data from the sensors
and understand
what's happening with the robot it
didn't know about this situation so it
was predicting things that were just
wrong
and then we did a violent shake and
fell off in our face first on out of the
robot
but like into the destination
that's true we fell in we got our point
for egress
but so uh is there any hope for that's
interesting is there any hope
for uh atlas to be able to do something
when it's just on its butt
and feet in the air absolutely so you
can woody
no so that's um that is one of the big
challenges and i think it's still true
um you know boston dynamics and and
animal and there's this incredible work
on on
legged robots happening around the world
most of them still are are very good at
the case where you're
making contact with the world at your
feet and they have typically point feet
relatively they're
balls on their feet for instance if that
if those robots get in a situation where
the elbow hits the wall or something
like this that's a pretty different
situation now they have
layers of mechanisms that will make i
think the the more mature solutions have
have ways in which the controller won't
do stupid things
but a human for instance is able to
leverage
incidental contact in order to
accomplish a goal in fact i might if you
push me i might actually
put my hand out and make a new brand new
contact
the feet of the robot are doing this on
on quadrupeds but
we mostly in robotics are afraid of
contact on the rest of our body
which is crazy there's this whole field
of
motion planning collision-free motion
planning and we write very complex
algorithms
so that the robot can dance around and
make sure it doesn't touch
the world um so people are just afraid
of contact
because contact is seen as a difficult
it's still a difficult control problem
and sensing problem
you